>> Sean: IN AN INTERVIEW WITH
"FOX & FRIENDS" EARLIER TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE GETS
ALONG WITH ROD ROSENSTEIN, GAVE
CREDIT TO MARK MEADOWS AND
OTHERS FOR EXPOSING WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE RUSSIAN WITCH
HUNT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I GET ALONG WELL WITH ROD.
WE HAVE A WITCH HUNT GOING ON,
WHICH IS DISGRACEFUL.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I'LL
TAKE THESE REPUBLICAN GUYS WITH
MARK MEADOWS AND JIM JORDAN AND
GATES AND GIBBS AND ALL OF THEM,
I HATE TO MENTION A FEW NAMES
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY OF THEM.
I WANT TO GIVE EVERY ONE OF THEM
CREDIT.
THEY'RE TOUGH, SMART GUYS.
THEY KNOW THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
IT TURNED OUT WITH RUSSIA.
THERE WAS COLLUSION BUT IT WAS
WITH HILLARY CLINTON, THE DNC.
THESE REPUBLICAN FOLKS, I THINK,
THEY'RE BECOMING FOLK HEROS.
THESE ARE GREAT, GREAT PEOPLE.
AND THEY WANT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH THAT, THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS, STAND BY THEIR
PROMISES, THEY FIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS JOINS
US.
FOX NEWS INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER
SARAH CARTER, THE HILL'S JOHN
SOLOMON.
CONGRESSMAN, WE NOW HAVE ROD
ROSENSTEIN, LET'S SEE, HE
RECOMMENDED FIRING COMEY, HE
SIGNED THE LAST FISA WARRANT,
THE THIRD RENEWAL APPLICATION, A
GUY THAT APPOINTED MUELLER.
THREE PEOPLE SAYING HE SERIOUSLY
WAS TALKING ABOUT WEARING A WIRE
TO INVOKE THE 25th AMENDMENT.
FOUR.
McCABE SAID IT, LISA PAGE SAID
IT, LET ME THINK OF THE OTHER
ONES, UM, ONE OTHER PERSON SAID
IT.
>> JIM BAKEER?
>> THAT'S IT.
>> YEAH.
I TELL YOU, THE REPORTERS THAT
YOU HAVE ON, I'M WITH TWO GREAT
REPORTERS THAT HAVE DONE
TREMENDOUS WORK ON THIS FRONT.
BUT I THINK PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
PART IS THE PRESIDENT, IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
HE KNOWS IT.
I KNOW IT.
EVEN THE DEMOCRATS KNOW IT.
AND IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT BOB
MUELLER, HE MUST FINISH THE
INVESTIGATION.
IT'S TIME TO CALL IT QUITS.
WHAT WE'RE STARTING TO FIND OUT
ARE THE WHEELS ARE COMING OFF.
GLEN SIMPSON, FUSION GPS,
REFUSED TO COME BEFORE CONGRESS,
TALK TO CHAIRMAN GOWDY THIS
EVENING, THE ONLY OPTION WE HAVE
NOW IS TO HOLD HIM IN CONTEMPT
OF CONGRESS.
>> Sean: WHY ISN'T THAT
HAPPENING?
WHERE ARE THE 302s THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO RELEASE?
WHERE ARE THE FISA WARRANTS HE
WAS GOING TO RELEASE?
>> WE HAVE GOT TO GET THOSE OUT.
FRANCE (SI IS GOOD IMMEDIATE --
TRANSPARENCY.
I'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR THAT,
THE PRESIDENT IS ADVOCATING.
BUT HE WANTS TO BE CAUTIOUS.
I APPLAUD THAT.
HE'S GETTING ACCUSED LEFT AND
RIGHT OF INTERFERING IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: INTERFERING?
THEY'RE OBSTRUCTING A
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION,
THAT'S YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE
TO YOUR CREDIT YOU'RE DOING.
SARAH CARTER?
>> OH, I COOPERATE AGREE MORE
WITH YOU, SEAN, ON THIS.
LOOK, WE HAVE ROD ROSENSTEIN,
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF INFORMATION
HAS COME OUT, IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS.
WE KNOW THAT JAMES BAKER, THE
FORMER GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
FBI CAME FORWARD AND SAID WE
TOOK SERIOUSLY WHAT HE SAID.
HE WANTED TO INVOKE THE 25ED.
WOO WE NOW KNOW.
>> Sean: WEAR A WIRE.
>> RIGHT.
SECRETLY RECORD THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
BEYOND THAT WE KNOW THERE WERE
TWO OTHER PEOPLE, APPARENTLY
SPEAKING WITH ROD ROSENSTEIN.
I GIVE THE PRESIDENT CREDIT FOR
THIS, SEAN.
THE PRESIDENT IS A GREAT CHESS
PLAYER.
I THINK HE'S MAKING HIS MOVE
NOW.
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT CAME
OUT, HE'S BEEN TALKING TO ROD
ROSENSTEIN, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED ON THAT FLIGHT, WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY
SPOKE ABOUT DURING THOSE 30
MINUTES.
BUT THE PRESIDENT IS LOOKING AND
WATCHING.
AND I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THERE
WERE OTHER PEOPLE INSIDE THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT WERE WITH
ROD ROSENSTEIN ON THIS.
IT'S GOING ON COME OUT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO COME
OUT NEXT WEEK.
BUT I THINK EVENTUALLY THE
PRESIDENT WILL MAKE IT PRESIDENT
IF HE'S ARE THE SMA.
THEN GET RID OF ROD ROSENSTEIN,
GET RID OF JEFF SESSIONS, PUT
OTHER PEOPLE IN PLACE.
THIS IS WHAT I HEAR BEHIND THE
SCENES.
THIS WILL HAPPEN.
>> Sean: LISA PAGE, JOHN
SOLOMON, SAYS FOR NINE MONTHS
THEY HAD NO EVIDENCE OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
JUST BEFORE THE APPOINTMENT OF
ROD ROSENSTEIN, TO MUELLER.
AND PETER STRZOK SAID THERE'S NO
THERE THERE.
NOW I THINK, WITH THE MEDIA LEAK
STRATEGY THAT WE HAVE BEEN BEEN
ABLE TO UNVEIL AND REPORT, ALONG
WITH THE INSURANCE POLICY
COMMENT, THEY LEAKED THE
INFORMATION TO DIFFERENT NEWS
SOURCES, IT ALL GOES BACK TO THE
CLINTON PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER,
CREATING THE ATMOSPHERE THIS
MUST HAVE REALLY HAPPENED WHEN
JUST THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
THE ONLY RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
CAME FROM HILLARY PAYING FOR
RUSSIAN LIES DISSEMINATED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND USED AS A
FRAUD ON A FISA WANT FOUR TIMES.
>> YEAH.
LISTEN, A LOT OF HARRY HOUDINI
GOING ON IN MAY OF 2017 AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A CASE, AND
INSTEAD THEY TRIED TO CREATE THE
AURA IN THE PUBLIC MEDIA THERE
WAS A CASE.
IT WAS OBSTRUCTED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
AND I THINK WHEN WE LOOK BACK IN
THE HISTORY WE'LL SEE A LOT.
I WAS THINKING BECAUSE OF THE
WORK OF CONGRESSMAN MEADOW,
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, DIGGING,
GLEN SIMPSON AND CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WERE OUT PEDDLING THEIR
STORY TO THE MEDIA TRYING TO GET
IT OUT BEFORE THE ELECTION TWO
YEARS AGO.
SHOWING POLITICAL COVERS.
TWO YEARS LATER, GLEN SIM SONL
CAN'T COME AND TESTIFY TO
CONGRESS BECAUSE HE HAS TO
INVOKE HILLS RIGHT AGAINST SELF
ININCRIMINATION.
HOW FAR HAS THIS INVESTIGATION
TURNED.
COLLUSION A RUSSIA, TO COLLUSION
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
THE FBI.
IT'S BECAUSE OF PEOPLE LIKE
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS AND
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN.
>> AND YOU AND SARAH AND GREG
AND OTHERS DESERVE CREDIT.
I CALL IT THE YEAR OF THE
BOOMERANG.
WILL WE GET THE DECLASSIFIED
UNREDACTED MATERIALS?
>> YEAH, I THINK WE WILL GET
THEM.
HOPEFULLY.
>> Sean: BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> BEFORE THE ELECTION.
HOPEFULLY SMALL GROUP OF THEM
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE THEM.
>> Sean: SR. RA?
>> ABSOLUTELY, WE NEED THE
DOSSIER, THE GANG OF EIGHT
PACKET THAT WILL DISCLOSE THE
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE, AND THE
302s.
>> Sean: JOHN?
>> NO DOUBT.
>> Sean: BEFORE THE ELECTION?